Il m'arrive qu'elle que chose de bizzare là !
A chaque fois que je m'éloigne d'elle plus de 3 minutes
Je reviens systématiquement au début de la colle.
A ça c'est marrant ça !
Ouais, bof...
Ah ouais c'est vrai, c'est pas très marrant.
C'est pour ici les pizzas ?
Oui, c'est pour moi
Qu'est ce que c'est là  ?
Mais ferme ta gueule !
Il faut que je trouve une fin à cette histoire
Il va falloir que je te laisse . On en reparle plus tard
C'est bon j'ai reussies, j'suis ...
Mais non !
Il m'arrive qu'elle que chose de bizarre là !
Je reviens systématiquement au début de la colle
A ça c'est marrant ça
Ouais bof
Mais non !
Non!
Ah ouais c'est vrai c'est très marrant
Qu'est ce que tu fais Marc à l'eau là ?
Mais ferme ta gueule !
C'est la caverne d'alli baba le truc
Il faut que je trouve une fin à cette histoire
Ont est pas obligés de trouvé cette fin là maintenant ?
Ecarter-vous ! Attention !
Pause ça tous de suite
Tu connais Bruce Lee là
Bon il va falloir que je te laisse. On en reparle plus tard.
;)